françois rebsamen le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir à soi et merci
d'être avec nous en séjour très
difficile on peut le dire pour le
pouvoir des sondages en chute libre
l'augmentation du chômage la
multiplication des plans sociaux et puis
la cohésion de la majorité
présidentielle mise à rude épreuve par
les verts sont ils toujours vos alliés
vous allez nous le dire dans un instant
françois rebsamen
il y également le budget de grande
rigueur ou de grande austérité qui sera
dévoilé vendredi un sujet que nous
aborderons tout à l'heure avec suzette
bloch de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire pour ce rendez-vous ensuite
avec perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous évoquerons votre combat une autre
contrariété pour le président de la
république pour le maintien du cumul des
mandats au moins pour les sénateurs
l'application tv tchèque d'orange permet
toujours aux téléspectateurs
d'intervenir et de poser leurs questions
au cours de cette émission d'abord donc
les verts les deux ministres écologistes
ont donc été maintenu malgré la position
hostile de leur mouvement au traité
budgétaire européen est ce que les
écologistes sont selon-vous encore
membre de la majorité dans ces
conditions là bien sûr bien sûr qu'ils
sont membres de la majorité que les deux
ministres qui ont été confortés par le
premier ministre sont membres du
gouvernement donc ils ont d'ailleurs
manifesté leur solidarité au
gouvernement et ils sont membres
ministre plein quand même nous sommes
mardi un mouvement qui exprime un crime
que l'âge fondamentale sur les grandes
orientations européennes et sur le
budget je ne le crois pas et je ne le
crois pas je bon mais je perds mais oui
je me permets d'apporter une nuance une
majorité d'écologistes est opposé à la
ratification du traité européen
certes mais les écologistes et c'est là
dessus que nous les attendons dans le
terme de la solidarité
les écologistes doivent être jugés en
terme de solidarité gouvernementale
en terme de solidarité de la majorité
sur à mon avis
orientation particulière la
réorientation de l'europe
voulue par le président de la république
c'est à dire ses choix européen à lui
les choix du président de la république
et et le la loi organique qui va
organiser la
la dépense budgétaire les règles
budgétaires pour les prochaines années
est ce que ce n'est pas ajouter un
manque de logique dans l'incohérence si
effectivement des élus verts refusent de
ratifier le traité et votent la loi
organique sur la règle d'or françois
rebsamen là on ajoute la confusion quand
même pour moi je le redis il ya deux
orientations qui prouve ou pas à la
solidarité et selah sue qui seront jugés
il ne doit pas y avoir la moindre faille
sur les orientations budgétaires que le
président de la république a défendu qui
figure dans ses engagements pendant la
campagne électorale et sur la
réorientation de l'europe qui l'a obtenu
permettez moi de vous savez le traité
reste le traité en privé en privé
beaucoup de responsables socialistes
s'indigne des comportements des verts
s'indigne c'est un bien grand nourrit
l'accusent par exemple de mélenchon et
aigus ou de choses comme cela entre les
cas de manque de cohérence
bon ça c'est c'est un jugement que je ne
porte pas sur une autre formation
politique personnellement je me permets
pas de porter jugement ce que je
constate c'est qu'il y a effectivement
au sein du mouvement europe écologie les
verts il ya j'allais dire une même
conception de l'europe
cette conception de l'europe c'est une
europe qui défend plus de justice plus
de solidarité plus de croissance durable
je n'ai pas forcément le cas dans le
traité lui-même stricto sensu et donc il
y a aujourd'hui un moment fort qui va
venir c'est celui du vote de la loi
organique sur le budget sur les
orientations budgétaires et le soutien
que je ne veux pas elles apporteront à
la réorientation ode au combat que mène
françois hollande pour plus de
solidarité la taxation des transactions
financières
et puis l'amélioration et j'allais dire
du contrôle bancaire
on a parlé des parlementaires d'europe
écologie les verts parlons des ministres
et notamment de ses fils duflot qui
refuse de dire s'il est pour ou contre
le traité budgétaire ça paraît quand
même surréaliste françois rebsamen a
écouté en tous les cas elle fait preuve
solidarité gouvernementale l e
reprend pas la position de
europe ecologie les verts dans sa dans
sa position affirmée soutient la liberté
de mes camarades en maintenant je
soutiens l'action gouvernement que
j'aime je crois pour en avoir discuté
avec mais c'est lui qui pourrait le dire
mieux que moi avec jean-vincent placé le
président ici du groupe écologiste au
sénat qu'ils vont laisser la liberté de
vote alors à leurs sénateurs donc
dont acte ou alors vous les écologistes
n'ont pas inventé la participation au
gouvernement sans soutien c'est vraiment
rejoindre la participation et le soutien
dans tous les cas moi j'ai je viens de
donner ce que je crois des limites qui
seront la preuve de la solidarité
gouvernementale de l'engagement de la
solidité de la majorité le budget on est
forcément le vote de la loi de finances
on est en est un c'est même l'acte
essentiel
et puis la loi organique on est d'accord
la conséquence directe pour le reste si
vous me demandez mon sentiment que
j'aurais préféré bien évidemment que
europe écologie les verts que je
considérais comme un parti et que je
considère toujours comme une formation
pro européenne qui a d'ailleurs obtenu
de très bons résultats aux élections
européennes il est vrai ont mené par
daniel cohn bendit qui a été mis en
minorité si j'ai bien compris
j'aurais préféré qu'il prenne une
position de cohérence sur le traité
européen
tel n'a pas été leur choix je le
respecte ça contient il ya un manque de
cohérence quand même vous
personnellement je m'aime encore au à
leur ombre on parle ensemble
à l'heure où on débat questionné si je
peux encore convaincre des députés ou
des sénateurs
europe ecologie les verts de voter ce
traité je le fais de toutes mes forces
pour autant je respecte leur choix de
parti politique car les dégâts sont déjà
là pour le chef de l'état qui a vu son
autorité bafouée
non je ne crois pas je ne le crois pas
ce qui fait la force de françois
hollande c'est d'avoir obtenu au sommet
européen fin juin cette réorientation de
l'europe
il est clair que nous aurions été dans
une situation très difficile
s'il n'y avait eu que le traité mais
pour sa crédibilité européen
on va voir qu'il n'est pas totalement
soutenu par sa majorité d'ailleurs il ya
aussi des récalcitrants parti socialiste
on va le dire bien sûr il ya toujours eu
lieu sur la question européenne
c'est une question qui a toujours divisé
la gauche pas de c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
pour monter en 1973
françois mitterrand pierre joxe a fait
hier toujours eu ce problème au sein de
la loge j'ajoute que quand la droite au
pouvoir existe aussi à droite on l'avait
vu au moment du traité de maastricht
traité de maastricht d'ailleurs que je
crois jean luc mélenchon avait voté dès
demain on a entendu jean marc ayrault
dire qu'il fallait un vote massif je le
rappelle sur ce traité budgétaire et je
me souviens que vous même vous avez dit
qu'aucune voix socialistes ne devait
manquer lors de ce vote en octobre est
ce que vous en êtes sûr ce soir
ben on s'y emploie vous savez comment la
démarche que nous avons retenu c'est la
conviction convaincre convaincre
convaincre et donc nous avons reçu
bernard cazeneuve le ministre chargé des
affaires européennes
nous essayons de démonter tous les
arguments de ceux qui sont contre le
traité et je ne doute pas que cette
force de conviction devrait devrait
remporter une très très large majorité
et c'est une occasion pour moi puisque
vous me le permettez d'appeler les élus
socialistes en responsabilité même pas
mes collègues députés je me permets de
le faire les sénateurs bien évidemment
il s'en fait moins nombreux les
sénateurs à voter non que les députés a
peut-être une voix manquera au sénat il
y en aura plus à l'assemblée nationale
mais nous ne désespérons pas avec bruno
le roux avec lequel j'étais tout à
l'heure de convaincre les députés
récalcitrants de de soutenir la chaleur
ils ont la république parce que quand on
veut vraiment soutenir l'action du
président de la république sur ce qu'il
a obtenu qui ne figurait pas j'allais
dire dans le traité sec qui avait été
acté entre madame mère était la passion
entre madame merkel oui mais y'a tout
l'environnement qui a changé est-ce que
je dois vous rappelez peut-être on peut
le rappeler que quinze jours avant
l'élection présidentielle on nous
annonçait une explosion des taux
d'intérêt pour les capacités d'emprunt
ou les
l'empreinte des français de la france
tout ça ne s'est pas produit on peut
considérer que le sommet européen de par
sa réorientation en termes de croissance
de solidarité financière de contrôle
bancaire a apporté une pause manger de
crise et la défense de l'euro reste un
peu vain car ciel heureusement que les
voix de la droite seront là pour faire
adopter ce texte
françois rebsamen mais je hausse énorme
pas affaiblir la france au sénat oui
puis en plus moi je vais pas faire de
distinguo en la matière non le dit oui
je considère que ce traité doit être
adopté j'appelle tous les élus de gauche
a voté ce traité puis si des centristes
il y en a qui soutiennent ce traité et
le rôle de le faire ils le faire en une
journée il demandé oui ça l'est pour
lesquels mais j'ai vu que une majorité
s'apprêtaient à le faire tourner tant
mieux tant mieux une autre mention
monsieur il paraît que vous avez fêté
aujourd'hui un ans d'alternance avec les
verts c'était la grande diffusion
non c'est pas on n'a pas fêté mais il ya
une restera une date historique dans la
vème république
c'est le 25 septembre 2011 le sénat pour
la première fois a connu l'alternance et
donc on a pris ensemble le verre de
l'amitié
il y aura dimanche une manifestation du
front de gauche est très remonté contre
le traité budgétaire et pour qui c'est
synonyme de camisoles d'austérité on
sent que la gauche radicale veut fédérer
tous les impatients est ce que ça vous
inquiète
c'est toujours non pas inquiétants mais
regrettable de voir que la gauche
ne rentre pas j'allais dire dans cette
pratique de se confronter à la réalité
du gouvernement et du pouvoir
donc si on veut vraiment faire avancer
les choses moi je suis respectueux des
positions des uns et des autres mais si
on veut vraiment faire avancer les
choses
il est clair que il faut accepter
notamment dans le domaine de la
construction européenne ce qui était des
petits pas est ce que font soit obtenu
françois hollande a obtenu c'est à dire
un grand pas un grand pas vers ce que
souhaitent nos collègues du front de
gauche c'est à dire je le redis ici mais
quand même des des centaines de
milliards d'euros qui vont être injectés
dans l'investissement dans l'économie
la taxation des transactions financières
ce n'est pas rien ça me fait penser par
moments à la position qu'ils avaient pu
avoir
monsieur krivine et au moins de la taxe
tobin il était député européen il avait
voté contre alors qu'il avait toujours
demandé parce que ce n'était pas assez
donc on peut considérer que c'est pas
assez mais l'europe se construit comme
ça aussi comment françois hollande
va-t-il s'y prendre selon vous pour
regagner la confiance de l'opinion
on n'avait jamais vu un chef de l'état
fut aussi vite dans les courbes de
popularité
oui mais que vous dire c'est pot sais
pas c'est pas une surprise la situation
extrêmement difficile celle que nous a
laissé aux bras sûrement parler le
gouvernement précédent et président de
la république sortant est extrêmement
compliqué extrêmement difficile on
savait que ce serait très dur et moi je
reprends cette formule de françois
hollande elle me semble tout à fait
juste ils ne demandent pas être jugé sur
autre chose que ses résultats
donc il a donné un agenda de
redressement
et puis on verra les français jugeront
le moment venu mais c'est pas en 100
jours ni en quatre mois que l'on va
corriger cinq ans d'incurie qui a amené
la france à un endettement record qui a
amené le taux de chômage à un taux
record qui année nos entreprises bien
souvent dans le mur qui a mené cette
succession de plans sociaux qui se
poursuivent encore en ce moment je pense
comme ça sanofi après psa ses
difficultés elle était là on est
confrontés à ses difficultés
si on peut comprendre l'impatience des
français fort légitime devant une
situation qui est très grave
le gouvernement fait face le président
de la république fait face il faut le
juger sur ses résultats sur est pas le
résultat de quatre mois sur sanofi ou
les syndicats dénoncent des
licenciements boursiers est ce que là
selon vous peut être enfin arnaud
montebourg a montré qu'il avait un rôle
à jouer puisque semble-t-il le nombre de
suppressions d'emplois a été revu à la
baisse mais mais il joue son rôle arnaud
montebourg il a il lui est tombé excusez
moi sur les épaules des plans sociaux en
rafale qui avait été retardée pour ne
pas polluer la réélection de nicolas
sarkozy
moi j'ai qu'une remarque a fait rare
moment de bourges profite de votre
émission
c'est certes il ya beaucoup de plans
sociaux dans notre pays c'est la
succession de ce qui a été laissé mais
en même temps il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui réussissent il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises qui se développe
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui créent
de l'emploi
il faut pas les oublier et j'ai un peu
tendance à ce que a trouvé que ont
noirci le tableau n'ont pas non pas de
la réalité parce qu'il est noir le
tableau est la réalité mais qu'on oublie
quand même de montrer ce qui va bien et
il ya des choses qui vont devoir et même
les entreprises qui vont bien réclame
quand même des aménagements pour leur
compétitivité on va en parler dans un
instant notamment avec suzette bloch de
l'agencé france presse qui va nous
rejoindre
on va d'abord voir françois rebsamen
comment votre fonction de président de
groupe
comment vous l'exercez et comment tout
ça est perçue au sénat pas seulement
d'ailleurs évidemment par les sénateurs
socialistes florence maurice on le dit
ferme avec ses opposants et habile avec
ses collaborateurs son principal atout
avoir les oreilles de l'elysée car il
est ami avec françois hollande depuis
longtemps et son mot d'ordre
le rassemblement france en laine est un
président de groupe qui laisse parler
permet que s'expriment toutes les
opinions pour lequel n'y a pas de sujet
ou deux pignons tabou après
il décide il ya tout juste un an le
basculement à gauche du sénat avait
ouvert une brèche droit de vote des
étrangers projet de loi de finances
pendant six mois sous la houlette de
françois rebsamen les socialistes ont
fait du palais du luxembourg
une sorte de laboratoire au service du
programme de françois hollande et a eu
deux périodes et une période très libre
septembre 2011 printemps 2012
et puis une période aujourd'hui où le
groupe a du mal à exister dans le
dispositif qui comprend le président le
premier ministre le gouvernement une
assemblée nationale où la gauche a plus
de 100 sièges d'avancé ou donc c'est
beaucoup plus facile de faire passer les
textes
kahoko sénat au sénat avec seulement
sept petits sièges d'avancé et une
majorité composite avec pas moins de
quatre groupes différents à gauche
l'équation pour françois rebsamen est
délicate jean-vincent placé le très
politique chef de file des verts a déjà
prévenu qu'il ne voterait pas le traité
budgétaire européen les verts une sorte
de caillou dans la chaussure des
socialistes dit on au sénat même si les
intéressés ne manque jamais une occasion
d'afficher leur complicité
moi je fais pas un poisson l'épreuve
reportée problèmes j'ai plutôt
l'impression de lui apporter une
majorité ainsi qu'au parti socialiste
jean pierre bel au sein du sénat et
commence à bien se connaître avec jean
pierre et françois et je crois dire
qu'on est un peu dans le même genre tous
les trois la pression c'est pas quelque
chose qui nous influencent beaucoup au
contraire reste que les sujets de
désaccord ne manqueront pas et que c'est
avec les voix de la droite que le traité
budgétaire européen sera probablement
accepter au sénat ça finira d'ailleurs
je le prédis monsieur rebsamen doit le
savoir moment ou à un autre il aura bien
un texte lourds qui passera pas au sénat
voilà donc vous allez pouvoir répondre
sur ce point monsieur karoutchi les voix
de la droite vous manqueront sur
certains textes essentiels outre le
traité si sept blocs nous a rejoint de
l' agence france presse pour parler
justement du budget d'austérité des
questions politico cela et puis d'autres
sujets d'actualité
oui on va commencer par un sujet
d'actualité importants la cour de
cassation vient de confirmer les
condamnations dans le dossier du
naufrage de l'erika
vous êtes soulagé oui qu'en pensez vous
il y avait un risque important il y
avait un risque important et puis ça
aurait été sorte de permis de polluer
qui auraient été données et donc très
heureux de la décision
il convient de les commenter toujours la
décision de justice avec grand respect
de la décision de la cour de cassation
d'accord bon revenons un peu maintenant
sur des choses un peu moins gai la crise
l'austérité va être avalisée vendredi
dans la presse dans la présentation du
budget 2013
c'est une pilule un peu difficile à
avaler pour les l'électorat de gauche
clair du tout d'abord je récuse ce terme
d'austérité
c'est un budget rigoureux ça c'est très
important bien gérés et la gauche va
bien gérée elle va le montrer historique
c'est un budget rigoureux parce que nous
sommes confrontés à la situation la pire
au niveau économique financier qu'un
gouvernement ait connue depuis des
dizaines d'années et donc nous héritons
d'une situation excusez moi de le
rappeler mais je le ferai
systématiquement nous héritons d'une
situation qui qui est très grave pour
notre pays et donc des engagements ont
été pris par le président de la
république pendant la campagne
ses engagements de rigueur au terme
d'une bonne gestion étaient mis en avant
par le président leur public ils vont
être tenues ils vont être tenues mais ce
budget vous allez le voir
c'est un budget qui préparent l'avenir
d'un budget qui définit les priorités
c'est un budget qui va soutenir la
croissance par l'investissement et
l'emploi
mais justement la croissance 20
milliards de hausse d'impôts dit
hier deux coupes dans les dépenses de
l'état est-ce que comprimer les dépenses
de l'état s'est aussi compris mais les
commandes de l'état est-ce que ça va pas
empêcher la relance 70%
madame blog vous le savez 70% de
l'investissement public 72%
investissements publics réalisés par les
collectivités locales
or il n'y aura pas de diminution des
dotations des collectivités locales dans
le budget 2013 ce qui veut dire que
elles vont pouvoir et je les invite à le
faire je le fais moi-même en tant que
maire de dijon continuer à investir à
soutenir par la commande publique par
les investissements réalisés les
entreprises et puis c'est un budget qui
préparent l'avenir parce que c'est un
budget qui donne alors ça donnera ça met
du temps on a demandé du temps sera jugé
sur les résultats
c'est un budget qui donne la priorité à
l'éducation d'un budget qui lutte pour
l'emploi des jeunes pour ne pas laisser
120 mille cent cinquante mille
décrocheurs en forme décrocheurs
c'est-à-dire sortir de l'éducation sans
rien donc pour moi c'est un bon budget
justement sur les collectivités vous
parlez de l'investissement des
collectivités
la dotation certes ne sera pas baissé
mais je vais pas être gelés oui elle
reste jules et je l'aimé il ya quelques
jours le président mais la critique et
le gel le vent les départements de
france on attend que saab était en
difficulté juste miley on va faire le
distinguo dans les différentes
collectivités
celle qui aujourd'hui investissent le
plus ce sont les opci excusez moi à les
communautés de communes communautés
d'agglomération on va dire les
communautés de communes les
agglomérations les communautés urbaines
les villes et les régions
aidée par les départements mais les
départements on va faire face je le mets
à part et de côté à des dépenses
sociales qui ont été transférés par le
dernier gouvernement qui alourdissent
leur propre budget mais ce qui est
préservée dans ce budget pour les
collectivités locales
c'est la capacité d'investissement et
c'est ça qui nous préoccupe le plus
l'investissement parce que vous le savez
l'investissement c'est la clé de la
croissance il y un consensus des
économistes pour dire que 3% de déficit
public ça va étouffer ça va étouffer la
croissance
même claude bartolone le président de
l'assemblée nationale convient que c'est
intenable qu'est ce que vous en pensez
non seulement de nam mais c'est un
engagement qui sera tenu je dois le dire
ici
enfin j'ai eu l'occasion d'en discuter
et on n'est pas d'accord avec mme
gertrude et avec le président de la
république et avec le premier ministre
ce que dit claude bartolone le président
de l'assemblée nationale c'est que ça va
être très dur à tenir mais oui ça va
être très dur à tenir mais nous pensons
nous d'ailleurs un agenda a été donnée
du redressement quand je dis nous
pensons le président de la république
l'a fait savoir
je pense que le premier ministre le dira
encore jeudi soir dans une émission qui
le fera nous pensons nous que nous
devons tenir cet engagement parce qu'il
y va de la parole de la force de
l'indépendance de notre pays nous devons
réduire notre déficit c'est vrai que ce
que nous laisse la droite
excusez moi ce que nous laisse le
gouvernement précédent c'est extrêmement
difficile passée de 9 6 3 pour c'est
bien sûr ça ne bougera pas mais bien sûr
cet engagement sera tenu
ouais à vous avez là dessus
mes conversations avec un chef de l'état
en tous les cas c'est la volonté du chef
de l'état on a abaissé volontairement
les prévisions de croissance pour se
rapprocher du du consensus des
économistes
alors qu'en s'y attendait un petit peu
suivant ce qui va se passer au niveau
européen c'est vrai qu'on est dans une
conjoncture très mouvante
il faut le dire au niveau européen mais
la droite aidés avait laissé avec des
espérances de croissance de 1,7 pour
cent en vrais documents sûrement plus
près des 08 que des as est donc les
efforts qu'il faut faire on les fera
et vous dites aux français on va faire
les efforts ils vont faire des efforts
20 milliards d'impôts enfin la moitié
sur les sur les ménages mais en sortir a
guéri parce que certains économistes
effectivement disent on va sortir et
guéri mais on sera mort
mais non mais non on peut la ligne de
crête qui a choisi le président de la
république qui a étalé je vous le
rappelle la réduction du déficit sur une
année de plus que ce que promettait
nicolas sarkozy puisque l'engagement
c'est pour fin 2010 est d'arriver à
l'équilibré budgétaire 0% alors que
c'était fin 2016 avec nicolas sarkozy
c'est vraiment une énorme 30 milliards
moi je d'efforts c'est nécessaire c'est
nécessaire sinon il a fallu plus faire
peser le poids de cet effort sur l'état
plus économique et moins d'impôts et des
lots situés la croissance la maigre
croissant et l'état l'état un rôle dans
le soutien à la croissance par ces
investissements aussi donc nous avons
aujourd'hui une ligne de crête qui est
difficile c'est un budget de justice
parce que ce qui va se passer c'est que
c'est ce qu'ils n'ont pas été mis à
contribution pendant les cinq ans qui
viennent de s'écouler les grandes
entreprises oui je peux le dire ici qui
meurent est appelé à un effort
particulier celles du cac 40
et puis les ménages de plus le
management les ménages les plus aisés
c'est en ses moyens aussi avec le chef
du barème de l'impôt tni seront
concernés on parle oui oui mais sur ce
point vous savez que les décisions
avaient été prises en amont et que nous
allons sortir pour les deux tranches le
plus bas là il y aura une décote pour
les deux premiers et lens est ce que
vous pensez inéluctable à terme françois
rebsamen qu'on n'augmente à cg et la tva
la tva sociale on a vous pouvez
l'appeler autres autrement parce que
c'est associé nicolas sarkozy pour
alléger les charges sur les entretenir
j'évacue cette idée récurrente que je
vais ressortir de tva on vient d'annuler
la hausse ce qui était prévu qu'ils
allaient amputer le pouvoir d'achat
parce que le pouvoir d'achat la
consommation
c'est de la croissance de demain donc on
vient de l'annuler c'est pas pour là je
ne sais pas d'où sort cette idée elle ne
l'a pas certains dilemmes à d'autres
sommets niang oui mais laisser faire le
gouvernement voyez les voiliers les
propositions et attendons aussi parce
que c'est un élément important la
résultante des négociations qui ont lieu
aujourd'hui entre patronat et syndicats
notre organisation sociale
à propos de volontarisme le droit de
vote aux élections locales
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est le
moment les sondages ne sont pas morts
l'ump a lancé une pétition
manuel valls exprime ses réserves du jeu
en lui-même que c'était pas le bon
moment
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est assez
simplement rappelle que le sénat est à
la pointe faut laisser la beauté le
sénat a adopté ce texte dans un
rassemblement de toute la gauche
au moins de décembre de l'année dernière
j'avais une belle unité avec les
écologistes
oui puisque vous verrez il ya plein de
textes contrats avec nos amis
écologistes notamment le budget les
e
les conditions aujourd'hui sont les
suivantes il ya soixante engagements du
président de la république c'est 60
engagements seront tenus mais personne
n'a dit qu'il devait être tenu avant la
fin de l'année 2012
donc ces engagements seront tenus il
n'est pas interdit en politique de
choisir les bons moments pour faire
avancer les textes c'est indispensable
pour les municipales non justement
moi je ne crains pas de le dire si cela
permet je le dis comme cela si cela
permet de démontrer qu'il n'y a aucune
volonté manipulatrice d'électorat
derrière cela eh bien pourquoi pas sorti
des municipales je suis pour le droit de
vote puisque je vais voter j'ai porté
des étrangers aux élections locales
cette proposition que nicolas sarkozy
avait reprise par trois fois qui faisait
rassemblement à un moment nous devons
convaincre c'est une belle formule du
premier ministre des esprits éclairés et
y en a au centre et à droite que c'est
pas une mesure électoraliste
c'est un engagement à nouveau droit
c'est un nouveau droit
elle peut attendre la fin du quinquennat
c'est très important vous dites on peut
laisser passer les prochains m6 si la
bonne foi
s'il faut convaincre de notre bonne foi
de la volonté de réussir cette réforme
parce que c'est un engagement du
président de la république on trouvera
le moment le plus adapté et si ça peut
aider des esprits éclairés en leur
disant voyez qu'il ya aucune
manipulation électorale derrière
pourquoi pas en tous les cas vous n'avez
pas le choix en fait parce que vous
savez bien que ce n'est pas la majorité
des trois cinquièmes
nous il nous marier au minimum
aujourd'hui une trentaine de voix
d'après les pointages vous dites ça vaut
pas le coup de tenter le référendum sur
le sujet comme ça non non je suis pour
dépôt d'un d'un projet de cil et de loi
du gouvernement sur ce texte et je suis
pour que nous essayons de convaincre de
trouver ces trois cinquièmes et donc je
suis sûr que quand on les regarde de
bonne foi quand on les rencontre de
bonne foi des centristes et les gens de
droite sont favorables à cette
disposition se pressaient comme le dit
manuel valls sur la durée
mais tous les appartements tous les
engagements valve sur la durée ce que
les partisans un les partisans de votre
camp du parti socialiste pour cette
mesure les écologistes qui dit ils
veulent l'application dès 2010 à 9,1 ils
vont pas nous faire je le dis avec
humour ils vont pas nous faire tous les
jours une pétition pour demander
l'application de tel ou tel engagement
du président de la république on aurait
60 engagement à tenir on va les tenir
ses engagements qui seront tenues mais
le temps qu'il faudra bah oui sur la
durée du quinquennat comme auquel son
final peut-être sur gérard collomb votre
collègue a eu des propos c'est un peu
sévère leur estomac visibilité
j'avais comme les décisions claires pas
d'incohérence ont dépensé avec des
emplois d'avenir retour partiel de la
retraite à 60 ans on m'appelait impôts
en même temps ils ont leurs épouses le
savent pas où elles vous qu'est ce que
j'ai je les ai vus aux journées
parlementaires à dijon il a eu
l'occasion de s'entretenir avec avec le
premier ministre
ce que soit dior que l'on sait que la
gauche réussisse et donc il
il dit les choses qu'il ressent il dit
des choses qu'il ressent pour vous la
politique ne manque pas de lisibilité la
politique du gouvernement
ben j'espère avoir démontré un
effectivement la pédagogie et soulever
ce mot et je je je le dis je pense que
collectivement nous permet de le dire
ici nous avons peut-être pêché par enfin
c'est pas un mots que j'emploie souvent
nous avons fait une erreur de ne pas
insister sur l'effet de traîne l'ère des
décisions qui avaient été prises avant
le 6 mai 2012 merci si vous êtes le brut
avec nous ce soir
perrine tarneaud de public sénat arrive
françois rebsamen pour vous interroger
cette fois sur votre combat contre
non cumul des mandats pour les sénateurs
d'abord sur ce sujet l'anc est
éclairante de jérôme rabier dans la
majorité il y a ceux pour qui le cumul
des mandats est plus un atout qu'un
handicap
françois patriat est l'un de ceux là à
la fois sénateur de la côte d'or et
président de la région bourgogne
le cumul est pour lui une question
d'organisation en moyenne deux jours et
demi au sénat plus si besoin et tout le
reste du temps tous les jours en région
si tous les jours aux régions j'ai là
devant moi le planning de cette semaine
hier j'ai fait la réunion de majorité à
la région je suis aujourd'hui au sénat
demain au sénat pour être à la
commission des finances
j'arrive très bien à faire charge de
cinq semaines n'ont pas réellement
métier double métier un avis que
d'autres camarades socialistes trouvent
bien peu convaincant certains en plus le
nom d'ubiquité que d'autres et mais on
peut dire quand même que globalement
ceux qui ont en charge d'un grand
exécutif ont tout même beaucoup plus de
mal à être présents au parlement que
ceux de leurs collègues qui n'ont pas
cette cette charge c'est une évidence
une étude menée à l'assemblée montre en
effet que les parlementaires ayant un
mandat municipal importants sont presque
deux fois moins présent que les autres
sans parler des conflits d'intérêts qui
peuvent naître de ses différentes
casquettes
c'est normal qu'un maire défendre son
territoire je dirais contre vents et
marées mais c'est pas normal qu'un
parlementaire celui qui fait la loi
défense que son territoire donc voilà
ces conflits d'intérêts qui se pose
qu'est-ce que soit la taille donc une
seule loi applicable pour tout le monde
un premier pas a été fait la semaine
dernière avec la proposition de ne pas
cumuler les indemnités avant de limiter
le cumul des mandats une façon de
montrer la bonne volonté des élus si
c'est ça le problème cette dérive est
trop d'argent
bah oui alors lorsque au lac
une indemnité pour un final aussi bas
très nerveux aujourd'hui les
parlementaires ne peuvent déjà pas gagné
plus de 8300 euros bruts tout le monde a
confondu ce nouvel effort ne sera donc
pas très important la future loi devra
surtout régler la question du statut de
l'élu local parfois payer seulement
quelques centaines d'euros car il ne
s'agit pas de décourager des vocations à
l'heure où et prôné le renouvellement de
la classe politique aux questions à
notre expert vous êtes venu avec votre
agenda comme celui de françois patriat
convient de voir ce que j'aimerais bien
savoir comment vous maire d'une grande
ville président du groupe socialiste is
you soon as avec toutes les réunions les
obligations que cela implique vous
arrivez en plus à faire votre travail de
parlementaires comme comme jean marc
ayrault l'a fait pendant une quinzaine
d'années où il était président du groupe
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale maire
de nantes député et président de nantes
métropole avec une bonne organisation
avec peut-être un surtravail will
personne ne le nie mais je crois être
très présent et au sénat et dans ma
ville et donc les est d'accord avec
cette étude dont parlait le journaliste
à l'instant dans le reportage qui montre
qu'un gros mandat municipal diminué de
45% à peu près la présence en commission
et dans l'hémicycle je n'essaie pas de
défendre ainsi le cumul des mandats
parce que pour le sénat parce que c'est
une problématique plus d'organisation
territoriale de la constitution et de la
république mais nous ne constatons pas
cela au sénat j'ai fait plusieurs fois
des pointages vous avez des personnes
qui ont des responsabilités locales
importantes qui sont présentes tard le
soir
voilà
jacques uige sera pas forcé chacun
s'organise donner l'exemple
je vous donne l'exemple de député mais
je me garderai de dire les noms qui
n'ont qu'un mandat et qu'on ne voit
jamais ou pas souvent à l'assemblée
nationale donc ce n'est pas forcément
une façon de lutter contre l'absentéisme
sais pas comment ça s'est passé chez
sûrement une manière d'améliorer les
choses mais je crois pas que ce soit
l'élément le plus important l'élément
essentiel parce que vous avez vous déjà
fait passer des amendements directement
liées à votre ville de dijon par exemple
françois rebsamen sait que c'est le cas
on va pas forcément les dénoncer ici de
certains grands élus qui ne sont là que
pour faire passer des textes en rapport
avec leur ville leur département et non
cycle dit l'ancien c'est ce que dit jean
pierre sueur par exemple ceux qui ont
été battus comme jean pierre sueur aux
élections municipales peuvent
aujourd'hui se réclamer du non cumul des
mandats
pénalité comme claude dilain sénateurs
qui bien sûr c'est très différent
suivant puisque vous savez qu'on a deux
modes d'élection à la proportionnelle et
au scrutin majoritaire c'est pas la même
chose mais nous avons souvent l'intérêt
l'intérêt d'une
d'une ville d'une d'une ville c'est
l'intérêt de toutes les villes il n'y a
pas d'intérêt particulier d'une ville
j'aime bien qu'on me cite ce que peut
être l'intérêt particulier d'une ville
quand nous votons par exemple la loi sru
quand nous votons la loi sru va nous le
votons pour l'ensemble des villes
j'entends cet argument ces dispositifs
budgétaires qui intéresse
particulièrement un territoire c'est une
enfance en route pour accéder en général
à ce moment là le gouvernement s'y
oppose
si ce n'est pas d'intérêt général ou le
savez très bien les dispositions
budgétaires ne peuvent pas être approuvé
sur proposition malheureusement j'allais
dire da sénateur ou d'un parlementaire
ou d'un député
mais l'argument est recevable l'argument
est recevable et donc gouvernement prône
sinon pas l'interdiction
je veux m'excuser je vous indique mais
est-ce que ça fait 35 ans que 40 ans
depuis 1958 que notre république
fonctionne comme ça des grandes avancées
ont toujours été faites par la gauche en
1984 sous la présidence sous le
gouvernement de laurent fabius pierre
joxe à limiter à deux mandats
aujourd'hui on parle de la limitation
non pas du cumul des mandats
mehdi cumul d'un mandat parlementaire
avec une fonction que j'ai supplié
locale
je me permet par exemple réclamer votre
encore on comprend votre amour pour
votre ville un sens et connaissant le
con ça c'est notre ancrage local en
étant conseiller municipal comme ça ne
vous suffirait pas oui mais moi je
plaide l'impuissance et exit verna
mesure monsieur jeu proposera des
amendements il faut accepter ou pas on
verra c'est le rôle d'un parlementaire
je l' ai dit au premier ministre
présente un public avec le brésil
municipal pas forcément premier
magistrat de la ville mais ça ça va être
le sens de la proposition du projet de
loi qui n'est posée par n'est pas
d'accord le gouvernement je plaide pour
le sénat
je suis pas forcément suivi là vous avez
interrogé quand même un panel de
sénateurs mais je peux vous dire que sur
les 130 sénateurs du groupe socialiste
qui est soutenait ma position n'était
plus une centaine donc oui mais il avait
dit à mes chiens
il y avait gérard collomb aussi et
d'autres et d'autres qui donc le cas
particulier du sénat je je moi je suis
tout à fait prêt à entendre tous les
arguments sur ce thème j'ai moi même
considéré je vous pensez vraiment que le
sénat pourrait se différencier sur ce
thème de l'assemblée nationale avec un
risque sans doute d'inconstitutionnalité
pourquoi pourquoi la constitutionnalité
ouais c'est ce que de délit un nouveau
traitement pour ce qui représenterait
uniquement les collectivités locales
c'est à dire qu'on va on se dirigerait
alors vers un système à l'allemande
oui moi je suis plutôt favorable à une
réflexion si je veux que je sois global
le président du sénat n'est pas en phase
avec moi là dessus
oui je le comprends très bien il défend
sa conception de l'institution je suis
je trouve ça tout à fait respectable -
je défends une organisation bi caméral
le bicaméralisme avec le bicamérisme
pardon avec à ceignac français qui
ressemblerait au bundesrat
voilà d'accord est ce que la commission
jospin vous semble légitime pour
réfléchir et proposer des solutions à
ces questions et pas mal de
parlementaires qui remettent en cause la
légitimité de la commission jospin ce
dont je veux pas remettre en cause la
légitimité de la commission jospin mais
les parlementaires sont tout à fait
aptes à reprendre cela elle modifier
comme cela viendra c'est le rôle des
parlementaires c'est pas le rôle de la
commission jose par claude bartolone
lors d'une conférence de presse ce matin
à l'assemblée nationale a dit vouloir
renoncer à son pouvoir de nomination
personnel au conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et le donner à la
commission des lois de l'assemblée est
ce qu'il faudrait faire la même chose au
sénat c'est pas c'est pas une mauvaise
idée ça ça mérite d'être réfléchi ce
qu'on veut marquer là c'est la
dépendance totale de la magistrature par
rapport au pouvoir législatif et donc
c'est sûrement une démarche dans
laquelle on peut s'engager oui j'ai
trouvé que c'était une bonne idée à
creuser au sénat d'accord dalil proposé
à jean pierre bel président du sénat rva
je préfère quand même que c'est effet
d'annonce soit fait en concertation
voilà vous voulez dire que ça manquait
de concertation avec le président du
monde est dans son rôle en tant que
président de l'assemblée nationale après
tout c'est son pouvoir de nomination
mais moi je peux pas répondre pour le
président du sénat prévu un affichage
quand même très vertueux du président de
l'assemblée nationale on a appris
aujourd'hui qu'il employait sa femme
comme chargé de mission à son cabinet
est ce que vous êtes surpris je ne
savais pas pezula prend là vous me
l'apprenez il a confirmé effectivement
en disant qu'il était en fait de sa
collaboratrice avant de devenir sa femme
enfin il est là dans son cabinet ce que
le principe de 25 ans
pas de pas de pas de commentaires je je
je découvre cette information le débat
sur les collectivités territoriales et
les états généraux il ya une grosse
réflexion engagée par le sénat mais
comment réformer les collectivités quand
les sénateurs les parlementaires sont à
la fois juge et partie
heureusement qu'ils sont juges et
parties parce que c'est eux qui ont
animé jeu par les sénateurs l'ensemble
des débats qui ont eu lieu dans
l'ensemble des départements de france
aujourd'hui on est juge et partie et
même si demain nous ne sommes plus que
élu local sans responsabilité exécutive
on sera toujours le juge et partie c'est
toujours ici au sénat élu par les grands
électeurs dont parle j'ai lutté réversif
c'est exactement ce que j'allais précisé
la différence essentielle quand même
avec les députés je veux bien qu'on ne
reconnaisse pas de spécificité du sénat
mais il y en a une qui est reconnu par
la constitution puisque les textes qui
concernent les collectivités locales
c'est déjà une première amorce elles
doivent être ils doivent être d'abord
présenté au sénat et donc il y a le
sénat elle représentants des
collectivités locales
il est les sénateurs sont élus par un
collège de grands électeurs qui sont
membres d'exécutifs voilà si on allait
être difficile pour vous dans gallimard
guerre je vais vous dire si on on non
pas du tout parce que vous allez voir
que les propositions ont décapé parce
qu'il est remonté de la base des
propositions moi j'en ai entendu dans
mon département qui vont être novatrice
est très intéressant
je voulais dire si on allait vers la
limitation du cumul des mandats on doit
on doit avoir une réflexion globale
1 le statut de l'élu vous l'avez rappelé
mais c'est là bas c'est oui mais c'est
la priorité on a beaucoup avancé quand
même
depuis longtemps on a bien avancé
aujourd'hui on va on va l'améliorer
premièrement deuxièmement une réflexion
doit avoir lieu notamment pour pour le
sénat parce que à ce moment là je
proposerai un amendement de repli à la
fin pour dire que celui qui est
titulaire d'un exécutif local ne peut
pas être candidat à un poste de
parlementaire
s'il n'a pas démissionné l'année d'avant
pour l'égalité de candidature vous
comprendrez très bien vous vous
comprenez mais je peux vous assurer que
les députés vont comprendre très vite si
demain ils sont à affronter des mères
qui eux si jusqu'au dernier moment en
tant que maire et qu'ils ne sont que
député il va y avoir du mouvement dans
tous les sens mais ce que ça suffira à
garder le nombre en 2014
à gauche ça ça dépend de notre capacité
à convaincre du travail que nous faisons
et je pense qu'avec jean pierre bel le
président du sénat ces états généraux
des propositions intelligentes que nous
allons faire et bien les élus locaux qui
ont été stigmatisées pendant cinq ans on
l'a vu à travers la dernière élection
sénatoriale
ils reconnaîtront les efforts que nous
faisons et les idées qu'on porte en
péril
un partenariat avec orange et leur
application tv tchèque pour cette
émission est là on a une question de
alice qui habite à bois colombes et qui
vous demande si vous allez marier des
couples homosexuels dans votre mail
dijon une fois que la loi sera votée au
parlement
oui bon c'est oui je le ferai je fais
des pacs en mairie
je serai très fier de marier un nouveau
droit j'ai porté un badge de 31,4 et
l'engagement que nous avions pris de
marier des homosexuels si nécessaire la
mairie s'il le demande selon moi ce que
vous riez évoluer le quinquennat après
ses débuts difficiles basse et des
débuts très difficiles mais nous nous y
attendions vu ce qui avait été laissée
je retombe dans cette nécessité de la
pédagogie
les plans sociaux certains
rappelons-nous psa il avait été annoncée
un an avant donc le déficit 650
milliards de dettes supplémentaires le
déficit laissé la croissance en berne
tout ça on s'y attendait à ce point là
peut-être pas à ce point là peut-être
pas et donc on doit répéter sans cesse
aux françaises et aux français qu'on
comprend leur impatience
en termes d'emplois notamment et c'est
là dessus que le président la république
va présenter un dispositif avec son
gouvernement complet des emplois
d'avenir des contrats génération j'ai vu
qu'ils allaient être présentés fans
auraient fait confiant mais bien sûr je
suis confiant heureusement que je suis
confiant et même je suis persuadé qu'on
va réussir
merci france arabe semaine d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui merci perrine pan
soir à tous et à la semaine prochaine
c'est mon avis
c'est la première fois donc on se
demande toujours si on va bien faire ça
va pas se tromper
j'ai pris de bons papiers c'est pour la
première fois
trop contente citoyenne reconnu à part
entière gentille et une émission très
politique ce soir on est entré dans une
nouvelle phase de la campagne avec
l'intronisation de nicolas sarkozy toute
ma vie j'ai rêvé d'être utile un aveu
j'ai pleuré mais qu'il sentit tout seul
majorité les socialistes espèrent un
rebond dans les sondages au lendemain du
discours programme de frigolet mme royal
et la ferme volonté d'empoigné ses
problèmes à bras le corps
chénard cheville est encore les gens se
souviennent d'un sourire d'une attitude
une expression d'un chef des gens se
souviennent de moins en moins de ce qu'a
dit l'homme politique
je crois que je serai élu président de
la république au qg de campagne de l'udf
beaucoup cette semaine leur confiance
la présidentielle on a eu droit à un
festival d'innovation mais vers le haut
et même si on vit plus longtemps et si
vous voulez quoi retraite je dois payer
il faut qu'on cotise plus longtemps
c'est pas marrant entendre c'est pas
malheureux à dire mais ya pas deux pays
au monde qui fait différemment vous
pouvez chanter tout ce que vous voulez
mais chez nicolas sarkozy vous a cité
dans son discours il a bien fait il a
bien fait mais alors vous allez nous
expliquer pourquoi car il candidat aux
municipales il me fera jamais assez de
publicité aux riches et la république
il a quand même pas été désigné par une
tribu de pas puni par un coup d'état
salut à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette septième saison d'avant de
bull cette année sans tabou sans peur et
sans reproche
on vous propose toute l'actualité du 9e
art et des arts graphiques à travers
évidemment les séries mais aussi les
auteurs quel qu'il soit les blockbusters
et les séries plus intimiste on va vous
faire découvrir ce neuvième art
tellement réputés et reconnus en france
en europe mais aussi dans le monde
entier un monde de bulles
l'émission consacrée au neuvième art
vendredi à 23h sur public sénat
de cet horizon du nid point c'est entre
la corse et l'italie l'île d'elbe qui
est arrivé un homme ce matin du 1er mars
cet homme c'est napoléon qui sur cette
plage où je me trouve la plage de golfe
juan
entouré d'une poignée de fidèles a tenté
ici même un dernier coup de poker qu'il
s'agit pour lui de ravir le pouvoir en
place celui d'un roi louis xviii
installé à paris aux tuileries et
surtout surtout de reconquérir le coeur
de son plein
bonjour à tous dans cette édition d'un
lieu une histoire nous allons vivre
revivre ensemble les premiers pas de ces
fameux 100 jours de l'empereur avec ceux
qui ici même font vivre et perpétue
cette mémoire la mémoire de cette épopée
de gaulle fusion nous sommes 0 à cannes
à quelques lieux d'ici puis à grasse un
peu plus au nord où l'empereur déchu a
entamé sa course folle à travers les
alpes vers paris surtout vers son
nouveau destin
ici à golfeuses sur le débarquement de
napoléon il est très très présent
napoléon d'ailleurs est omniprésent dans
l'ensemble de la ville et tous les deux
ans ayant on reconstitue ce débarquement
napoléonien une reconstitution à un
grand uniforme
philippe autier est l'une des chevilles
ouvrières de cet événement bonjour
philippe lauthier alors vous
reconstituer j'allais dire exactement ce
qui s'est passé ici sur cette plage tout
à fait on reconstitue le débarquement de
napoléon le débarquement de ses troupes
également il faut savoir que napoléon
est parti un acte de l'île d'elbe la
traversée s'est passée comme d'hab le
mans et le 1er mars 1915 alors que
personne ne l'attendait il débarque sur
cette planche alors on revient sur cette
traversée de l'île d'elbe une île
coincés entre l'italie et la corse
jusqu'ici est ce que la traversée s'est
bien passé pour nous voler alors cette
traversée s'est très bien passé il a
croisé quelques navires anglais qu'il a
réussi à éviter
il débarque à golfe-juan le 1er mars
1115 sans avoir tiré un coup de canon en
mer et à un moment où personne ne
l'attendait alors napoléon a été observé
quand même de très très près juste
derrière vous il ya les îles de lérins
et ce fameux port ste marguerite où
étaient présents des troupes fidèles à
louis 18 3 alors ce jour là bizarrement
tout l'état major de la garnison
d'antibes organisé une visite
d'inspection sur le fort sainte
marguerite et ils se sont étonnés de
voir en baie de golfe-juan quelques
bateaux qu'ils ont pris part pour des
bateaux barbaresques qui venaient faire
une razzia de plus et le général cours
scène dans son rapport dira qu' en aucun
cas y penser
qu'il s'agissait du débarquement de
napoléon philippe pottier qui était avec
napoléon ce jour-là napoléon de peu de
monde ce jour-là il y avait son
état-major présent l'île d'elbe et une
troupe de 1000 personnes
on est à quelques kilomètres à peine
d'antibes en tibre célèbre également
pour son fort un fort armée à l'époque
et napoléon s'en méfier de ce fort
napoléon koné centimes c'est la ville
frontière avant le comté de nice donc la
ville garnison importante et napoléon en
débarquant à golfe-juan il a choisi golf
gens parce que c'était pas tout à fait
intime mais il savait que la garnison
n'était pas loin donc il a débarqué il a
envoyé quelques émissaires pour essayer
de se rallier cette garnison qui en fait
est resté royal
regardez ces bateaux ils sont
extrêmement nombreux et pour cause nous
sommes au coeur du port de plaisance de
golfe juan
alors évidemment le 1er mars 1815 il
n'existait pas ce port de plaisance
était la plage d'une plage absolument
identique à celle où nous étions il y à
quelques instants et c'est ici sur ce
port de plaisance de la ville qui a été
érigé dans les années 60 une simple
stèle qui remémore ce débarquement de
napoléon en 1815
j'ai rejoint tout de suite pierre brand
d'agde et historien il travaille à la
fondation napoléon pierre brand ap on
appelait os qu'il n'aurait pas été plus
simple de débarquer en italie l'île
d'elbe elle est toute proche de la côte
italienne
en effet pour quelqu'un de moins
audacieux que napoléon c'était une
solution au mur à son beau-frère et n'y
est encore à naples il disposer de 80
mille hommes quelqu'un de logique aurait
dû prendre cette voie là où nord
d'italie où le sud de l'italie
napoléon va choisir la france pour des
raisons politiques mais aussi pour une
raison bien simple c'est là où on
n'attend pas donc le choix de golfe juan
n'est absolument pas dû au hasard